Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab, and today
we're going to begin in a place. Robert, come in here. Oh,
oh my God. A place full of wonderful things.
This is the actual lead that Hinton and Perry used to first go to the North
Pole. These are Napoleon's books and his conquest to Egypt.
Look at the antlers over there. So wait, where?
Where are you exactly before I tell you that, let me just explain something.
My wife and I, Hey, tame. I have been having an argument for roughly,
it's going on now 40 years.
And it's always about a things like objects, like objects. Yeah. So as you know,
you have a thing about things you give me like an autograph,
like an Abraham Lincoln autograph, I think. Okay. Yeah.
Blink and stood in front of this very piece of paper in order to write his
signature in this very way,
he had to be standing exactly where I'm standing and therefore he and I share
this space.
I literally believe that I am standing in Abraham Lincoln Shadow.
So to touch an Abraham Lincoln autograph is a form of time travel,
a form of love. It's all those things, and I can do that without even blinking,
right? Tamar, not at all,
but also Robert Sense of the magic of it extends to, we have a really,
really ugly floor lamp from a long time ago,
and every time I would say enough already, let's get rid of,
if you think it's older than me, I've had it all my life,
which makes it beautiful. Now you don't have that at all.
I don't have that at all. So in honor of our topic today,
I decided that we're going to settle this argument once and for all.
I took Tamar to the explorers club right here in Manhattan. Oh wait,
what's the explorers club?
It's a a little a private club where explorers deposit things that they
collected.
Everything in this building has some historical significance in some sense.
That's real. Roseman their executive director, he gave us a tour.
This is the actual bell from the SS Roosevelt when Pairing Hanson first went to
the North Pole.
Yeah.
Very cool. But not matching. Doesn't cut it.
The chair over there belonged to the emperor storage of China. The last emperor,
his wife at cheer there. He points to it looks like a little desk chair.
The embers tower. China sat in it. Yeah,
that was her chair is make you want to sit in it. Yes, yes, yes. I wouldn't.
You shouldn't at first she sits nothing.
You feel nothing but just close your eyes and imagine that you are the last
emperor skinny,
hugely long line of Chinese Enbridge's going back probably a thousand years.
I would order them to make more comfortable chairs. Wait, not, don't,
don't get up yet. Just give it a chance.
There's nothing that's going to seep into me. There is.
There isn't a, I dunno man. Look, look, this was never going to be easy.
Tamar is a New York Times reporter. Very reasonable, very sensible. After all,
it was just the chairs. It was just the beginning. I they have things in this.
I was going to break her step by step.
We'll walk us to the next room where they had pieces of fabric that would frame
on display racks of, you know,
early planes were made out of canvas and these are actual pieces of those early
planes. Here's the Wright brothers plane. What do you mean?
You mean this is the fabric from the actual first? Absolutely. Oh Man.
There was a small brown piece of fabric.
Not much larger than your fist was cut from the wheat of their first airplane.
So the wind, the wind
rushed over that little piece of fabric for the first time. Yeah.
Very cool. Very interesting.
Happy to see you when you're standing next to the fabric that lifted into the
sky for the first time in America,
you don't feel just a touch closer to over and over, right.
Not even a time I feel. What a wonderful collection. How interesting.
It's amazing. I mean, I'm feeling it. I'm feeling it. It's amazing. And Tamar,
do I feel that? No. So, okay.
I wasn't trying to pick it. Something that quite incorrect.
He's trying to pull out the big guns.
I don't see how you can get bigger than what you already offered. Well,
there's more there, right? Yeah.
Maybe this will convince you.
This is an actual flag and explorers club flag that accompanied Buzz Aldrin.
Neil Armstrong,
when they first landed on the moon in 1969 oh,
so this is one of these
that that piece of cloth right there it is. Yeah. It was on the moon.
Absolutely.
It was carried by Neil Armstrong when he first landed on the moon in 1969 oh my
God. It was in a little glass box.
You could see it was a royal blue explorers club flag.
Very small. Probably made of silk that let her touch it. Yeah, I can.
You know what I, I, I'll have hit that. Let's have her touch the flag.
That was the first flag I were ever on the day that humans got onto the moon.
Let you think. I will shoot every nation with all the way sparks yes.
In my body. And so you a special, yes. Yes.
Okay. We opened up the cabinet. You've now got it in your hands.
Okay, go ahead. All right.
It feels very nice. It feels like it's a little fun. This was on the moon? Yes.
This was on the moon. Brought there by the people who from our planet.
The first people ever to land on the moon and they brought this with them. Yes.
That's it again. Okay. You had it. Well, I'm going to touch it. Okay. Alright,
here I go. Do you need right? Oh Man.
[inaudible] coming down the ladder now.
I see. Okay.
A form of spare per man,
Andy Red attach it. I mean, I'm pretty pumped to it.
I'm fine about, or Tim or you don't
get any of this smell? I don't get a swoon. How could you make it?
There's room for me. I don't get as far as the first trip to the moon.
I know they send shivers up my spine. I mean, I don't have it.
I just, I don't have it, so I got to go to work, so, okay.
Total tree. That was our pleasure. Thanks so much for counting you.
You lose.
Maybe she's just open to the future.
She doesn't want to have to carry all that baggage. Then you came right.
You know you, that's what you're going into. A swoon about a lamp.
That's clearly an ugly ass lamps throughout the website. Give me an old lamp.
Let's let, let's be available to the new labs of the world.
I'm not cheating to admit or even consider anything you just said,
except that you're probably right about the future. I inpatient.
Do you know what else I'm right about what?
Every story that we have in this hours.
Basically that argument you just had with your wife in story form. Yeah, object.
In each of these stories there is a thing and the thing beckons or not
[inaudible]
today on radio lab things.
Everybody say something. Hello? Oh, hello. Hello. All right,
so where are we doing? Well, um, we're talking about objects, I believe. Yeah.
And I understand you guys are kicking around some ideas,
but it seems my ideas are in a bit of a different orbit than yours are.
Maybe there's a connection. Yeah. I don't know that we have an orbit yet.
I think we've launched, you're just sort of like, okay.
So our first story comes from a TV producer, Vin Liotta,
longtime DV Guy who um,
connected up with us because it turns out he is making a documentary about this
very thing.
People's connection to objects by my interest in objects is things that sort of
have accidentally gotten meaning for even even if you have a little scrap of
something that's gone to the moon and back,
it's nothing compared to Rick Rollins, sugar egg,
Rick Rollins sugar and Rick Rollins. Rick Sugar Egg. Yes.
Actually the story he wants to tell us has three parts. It's about a candy egg,
a box, and a tree. A candy egg box.
And the tree. Yeah. So this is what I would suggest is I have some clips,
some short clips, and I'd like to sort of weave the clips together, sort of get,
maybe throw it out that way rather than telling you about them. Uh,
why don't we, why don't we try? I see we're dealing with a storyteller. Yeah,
let's, we'll wait until you hear the clips. So, okay. Let me just play a clip.
This is like a short clip. This is just an intro to Rick. I love this box.
Wow. It's beautiful that the size of a shirt box it's made out of maple.
Very light in color. Very delicate.
And he keeps his most treasured objects in it. One of them is this sugar
egg that we were talking about. Not a real egg. No,
it's a molded sugar.
It's hollow in a center light yellow something someone might eat.
Um, someone might eat it. I, I have not eaten it. I um,
I've saved it since 1970 when I was given the sake
since 1970. What? He saved it. This is an editable egg.
This is an editable egg. Yes. They edible. If you kept it from 1970,
it looks remarkably good for dissolved and under the weight of time.
And it's, and I know apparently it's a, well, it's pristine.
I've seen it as a sugar egg. What is that?
Apparently it's a half of an egg. It's hollow. It's made out of sugar.
And you would put things like jelly beans in it.
You seal the edges with frosting and then you decorate the outside of it.
So there must've been some, a reason why he,
he has memorialized this. Oh, I'm glad you mentioned it.
I just happened to have another clip to play.
Imagine my surprise the day that we were to leave. Oh wait.
Can we stop for a second? Yeah, sure. I'm sorry. You know what,
I didn't set it up because, um,
one of the things I have to say about Rick was when he was a kid,
his family moved around a lot.
Apparently Rick's dad did a lot of work for the government.
So almost every year he would find himself in a totally different town.
And to make things worse, he was a very shy kid, kept to himself a lot.
So for Rick, friendship just often seemed impossible,
but then says there was this one moment when he was eight, they,
they lived in Washington state only for a year.
And he found himself in a dilemma because he had finally made a friend and his
friend David invited him to a birthday party.
But it happened to be that, uh,
his birthday party was scheduled the very day that we were to move again.
So my father was once,
once again transferred this time from Washington back to Idaho.
And my parents had decided that I couldn't attend the birthday party because
there wasn't time. So the moving van was sitting there,
everybody was ready to go. And I don't think I, I even asked my parents,
I don't think they know that I left,
but I took off and I ran up the street to David's house.
I still can picture this moment. I,
his house was a brick house and he had a large porch that was completely empty.
And I know that I paused there even though I was only eight,
I must've known that our friendship really wasn't at the point where it demanded
a good buy, especially if that meant that I had to interrupt his birthday party.
But I rang the doorbell and his mother answered the door and I remember seeing
basically from her knees down and beyond her into the back of the house,
which was bright and loud where the party was going on.
And a few later David showed up.
He was kind of behind her and I don't remember seeing a word
you were just standing. I was just frozen in standing there,
completely embarrassed and not knowing why I had done this. And uh,
I was about to leave when David's mom apparently asked him to go get something
and he left and a few seconds later returned and,
and handed me this yellow sugar egg.
[inaudible]
the very same thing here in your box. Yes.
I walked back to my parents' house.
We were loaded into the back of their station wagon and we drove from there to
Idaho. And I know that I held this in my hand the entire way.
Didn't let go of it.
I put it in a drawer and it is lived in various places for all these years.
Why? Yes. It begs the question, doesn't it?
You know,
the truth is I knew its importance immediately and it hasn't changed.
I looked at this egg and it was proof,
physical proof that I had been invited to a birthday party and that there was a
hope of making a friendship and I held onto it because I needed that proof.
[inaudible]
that's actually very wonderful. Yeah. Yeah, but, but we, there's the tree,
the tree. We did the box, we did the egg, but then there's the tree. Do we need,
do we need the tree of the egg? I'm all of, I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm swept into the egg. No, I'm bring it together.
I'll bring the narrative threads together. I will more egg vid.
Give me more egg. We need to play the, the tree. So yeah. My,
my parents bought a home in Idaho. This is right after the egg incident.
Yeah. This is in the Snake River valley in Idaho. It's very flat.
It's very wide. Their new backyard was a barren landscape. So my family,
they started planting all kinds of things in the yard.
They planted apple trees and pine trees,
Cherry and amongst them was a,
a maple tree that was Rick's favorite.
It grew very quickly and it envelop the house in a certain way in the breeze.
It sounded like suede rubbed together just
amplified by hundreds of thousands of leads.
[inaudible]
it was beautiful. Rick lived there with his family for 10 years until college.
I moved to Boston and I learned that my father had decided that the tree was
planted too close to the house and that was, it would damage the foundation.
And he, he
chopped it down.
It was a massacre. It was brutal. And, uh,
I was very upset. And so my mother,
knowing that she mailed me a package and I opened it to find that she had placed
in it, some small sprouted seedlings from the original maple tree.
Rick dug a hole in the backyard and plopped it in the ground behind the garage
and it thrived. It grew really well. And within a number of years,
it had grown to be a 30 foot tree. Reminded me,
obviously of the tree that I had loved and lost in Idaho.
And, uh, it became so large, unfortunately,
that it also caught the attention of my landlord who, uh,
tragically,
one night I got back from work to discover that he had chopped down the maple
tree, the son of the son of the tree. Same Grizzly n well,
you would think so I went out into the yard that night and I salvaged these
sections of the tree.
Rick gave the wood to a friend of furniture maker in Gloucester,
Massachusetts who turned it into a box. This box,
the one right here made from the maple. That grew from, you know the story.
Yeah. Wow. There's this continuity. I find such comfort from that.
So it in turn holds all these objects that have their own individual stories and
their own meaning to me. One of them is this yellow sugar egg,
the egg, the tree in the box. That's nice. That's really nice, man. Very nice.
Although, pardon me, it doesn't, it doesn't,
part of you want to smack Rick a little bit and be like, well no, you know,
I totally, okay. Is it a dream you're living in the past? No. God,
no. I actually don't, not me. Yeah.
We could put the box in a house weight made from the teeth of his dog with the
thing I would say. Okay. Yeah. Just keep loving like that.
Oh, how I wish we left it there. You know, some sort of the,
the thing about objects is that like you can't really experience them unless you
touch them and interact with them.
Like that's how you get the essence of what's in there. But at a certain point,
our producer, Lynn Levy,
who really produced the show had this great idea for an experiment that we could
do where we would make three d printed versions of the objects and the stories
and then public an exhibit where people can come and see them while they listen
to the audio.
Or even if they have access to a three d printer or they could just print a
version wherever they are. So we asked Rick if we could scan his egg.
I'm not sure what will happen, but I thought it was an intriguing idea.
He was game. So Lyndon found a place that does that near him.
We asked him to bring his, the egg in technician, put it into the scanner.
It's a machine that takes like 360 degree images,
which you can then use to print a replica.
Just a little bit of melted plastic and Voila. There it is.
And here's what happened. Rick, drop the egg off for a scan.
This egg that he had been cherishing for over 40 years.
I had to leave it for a couple of hours. Shortly after he does,
he gets a call from the scanning technician who tells him something happened,
you know, she said
the bottom line is the, um, I,
the egg is broken. She said,
I hope it wasn't a family heirloom fin.
Met Up with Rick as he was just getting back from the print shop with his bag of
egg pieces. I close this up at the store.
I didn't really even look too much.
Oh my God.
Looks like it's in about seven pieces and this plastic bag.
Here it is.
[inaudible].
Yes. Hi, is this Rick? It is Rick. How are you? This is Jad from Radiolab.
Chad. Hi. How are you doing? Yeah, I f I,
I just need to say that we are so, so, so,
so sorry about what happened.
I never had my heart sink in that way from any email I've ever opened.
Well I thank you. Thank you. It was such,
it was such a strange clash to walk into this store that is devoted to the
future and all these machines sitting around that are turning out almost
magically these new things.
And I on the other hand and standing there to collect the shards of a sugar egg
that I've held on to for 40 plus years and wow.
It just felt a dullness kind of heavy.
Like everything was just a little bit muddied for
awhile.
It took a little while for that to wear off and,
and it did with an amazing clarity.
Hey Max. Hey, one morning,
I think it was two days after the egg had been broken.
He says he woke up and an idea came to me, so I should call him
Max Egg Max is the son of a friend of his who lives down [inaudible]
the street. So we do one and a half tablespoons and he,
he's eight, exactly the same age that I was when I got the first day.
Okay.
Coviello Sea.
And so I asked him if he would help me recreate the sugar egg go away right
here. Kind of smiled and said sure. Yes.
Maybe two. Now that you've got some in there already.
[inaudible]
oh, Vlo Sayer. Nice speech scoop.
Go ahead. Right here already finishing a egg.
Oh, the one I was exactly your age,
so exactly. Exactly. You're sort of Nan,
I was invited to a friend's birthday party and I couldn't go.
[inaudible]
special thanks to Vin Liotta who provided us with much of the tape.
You just heard of Rick and, and uh, we'll pretty much the whole thing.
He is doing the documentary,
which is why he's got all that stuff about people who attach to everyday things.
Oh. And, and, uh, in terms of the, the egg breaking,
uh, we, we actually, we have,
we found somebody who does like restoration for movie stuff and we've offered
Rick to,
to have that person fixed the egg with epoxy or whatever and offer he agreed to
accept, happy to say, and also interestingly enough, um,
mid scan, you know the scan that broke the egg? Yeah.
Actually we have that scan cause the skin scanning machine was actually running
the very moment when the egg broke.
So we actually have a scan of the millisecond when it fell apart.
It's at radiolab.org.